let's say we have the simplest of
arithmetic sequences and probably the
simplest of sequences so one two we're
going to start at one and just increment
by one one two three and we're gonna go
all the way
to n
and what i wanna think about is what is
the sum of this sequence going to be and
the sum of a sequence we already know we
call a series so what is the sum and
i'll just call it s sub n what is this
going to be equal to 1
plus 2
plus 3
plus going all the way
all the way to n
well we're going to do a neat little
trick here where i'm going to rewrite
this sum so i'll write it again as s sub
n
s sub n
but now i'm just going to write it in
reverse order i'm going to write it as n
plus n minus 1
plus n minus 2
all the way to
1.
and now i'm going to add these two
equations so we know that s of n is
equal to this so we're adding the same
thing to both sides of this equation up
here so on the left hand side you're
going to have sub n plus sub n is just 2
times s sub n
and on the right hand side and this is
where we start to see something kind of
cool
you have a 1 plus an n which is just
going to be
n plus 1.
you have a 2 plus n minus 1 which is
well 2 plus n minus one is going to be n
plus one again
plus n plus one
you have a three plus n minus two well
that's going to be n plus one again
n plus one i think you see what is going
on here and you're gonna go all the way
to
this last this last pair i guess you
could say it or call it the this last
these last two terms
and we have an n
plus 1 again plus n plus 1.
so how many of these n plus ones do we
have
well we have n of them there were n of
these terms in each of these in each of
these equations 1 2 3 all the way to n
so we can rewrite this thing as 2 times
s sub n is equal to you have n n plus
one terms so we could write it as n
times n plus one
n
times n plus one
and now to solve for s sub n to solve
for our sum we can just divide both
sides we can just divide both sides by
two
and so we are going to be left with the
sum
from one to n this arithmetic sequence
we're just incrementing by one starting
at 1 is going to be equal to n
times n plus 1
over 2.
and this is neat because now you can
quickly find the sum let's say from 1 to
100 it'll be 100 times 101 over two so
very quickly you can find these sums
and what i'm curious about and what
we'll explore in the next video is can
we generalize this for any arithmetic
sequence we started with a very simple
one we started one we just incremented
by one and it looks like it looks like
this is so if i were to write it this
way this is n
times this is n times n plus one
over two
so this right over here this n
this is the nth term in our sequence and
this right over here this one was the
first term in our sequence so at least
in this case it looks like i took the
average of the first term and the nth
term so this right over here let me make
it clear this is the average actually we
do it like this
this right over here
is the average
of our of a sub 1 and a sub n
and then i'm multiplying that times n
and what i'm curious about is whether
this is going to be true for any
arithmetic sequence that the sum of it
is going to be the average of the first
and the last term times the number of
terms